Rebecca is with us in Boise Idaho hi
Rebecca how are you good better than I
deserve what's up well I'm just
wondering about what your advice would
be on how to balance helping family
financially and taking care of yourself
financially so I'm I'm completely
describe my situation my husband and I
have been married for almost a year we
have no debt you know about to start
school next month and we have a goal to
purchase a home next spring or summer so
we're doing great no complaints there
however my mother-in-law is recovering
some cancers and since she had no health
insurance they've got quite a few
thousand dollars of debt now due to the
medical bills he's probably not gonna be
able to go back to work and my
father-in-law is 68 he's partially blind
drawing from the Social Security already
and still works a little bit part-time
but it's barely enough to support them
they're renting they have no retirement
savings and they have all these medical
bills now their incomes about to go down
well I'm concerned about their situation
their future we try to send the money
periodically to help them out but to
reach our goals like school and how it's
like I said we can't keep helping them
to the same extent so what's your
household income collectively right now
it's about 52 oh okay and well here's
the rule you can only help others to the
extent you're strong enough to do it and
so if they if they need a million
dollars to pay off their medical bills
they don't but if they did you can't
help them you know the money right and
so at what point do you not have the
money is desperate and dyers their
situation is at what point do you just
not have the money you don't have a
million dollars even if you wanted to
you couldn't pay a million dollars to
help so how much in medical bills do
they have do you know about 15,000 okay
and you guys make 50 and how much money
have you been sending them we usually
send them just a couple hundred a month
however when I'm going to start school
I'll be working part time so our income
will go down by about ten thousand a
year so that'll change here soon
yeah okay and so you're going to be very
very tight to be able to even do that
all right so basically the question
comes down to prioritizing and you know
I've been told that as well that's the
best way to help others is to set
yourself up well first but from a
Christian perspective it almost seems
selfish and I feel like I can't stop
stop stop so why is it selfish from a
Christian perspective to take care of
your own family because our we're set up
well enough right now that we don't have
to buy a house in a year that's our goal
we can put that on hold and they'll help
them in the near future in ignoring
their need and helping them later
there's not a biblical mandate for you
to do that though so I'm not gonna take
a Christian guilt trip on this Curtin
Bible clearly says clearly take care of
your own household first or you're worse
than an unbeliever that's pretty that's
pretty strong so do good people and
create including Christians we want to
help mom and dad when they're struggling
absolutely but we're not going to
spiritualize this and make you like a
bad Christian if you don't send them
$200 okay
that's absurd now once we've said that
but good people want to help and you
want to help
and certainly your husband wants to help
and I want to see I want to see you be
able to help them so $200 a month
doesn't keep you from buying a house in
a year you going to school might keep
you from buying a house to you but $200
a month is twenty four hundred dollars
if you're twenty four hundred dollars
off for buying a house you weren't ready
to buy a house anyway so what I want to
do is I want to get up under this
because what the problem is is it feels
like there's no end to it for you
and I helping them and it looks a little
mathematically like there's no end to it
number one I wouldn't pay a dime of
medical bills and I wouldn't have them
pay a dime of medical bills until they
have met their basic needs and that's
true of anyone I'm coaching okay and
their basic needs are food shelter
clothing transportation and utilities
and so he has the Social Security check
coming in how old is your mother-in-law
okay so she's not gonna draw right now
unless she's declared disabled and and
they have absolutely no money anywhere
is what you're telling me aside from the
Social Security I mean they're broke I
don't own anything and they don't have
any money all right and that's what
concerns me their incomes about to go
down and so they are you know what
you've got to do if you really want to
help is it's it's more trouble than just
sending a two hundred dollar check you
need to get with your husband and with
them are they in the same town you're in
by chance I know they're about four
hours away and maybe you jump on the
phone or maybe you jump over there one
weekend and you lay out a budget of how
they're gonna make it for the next 20
years or the next ten years or five
years until she gets Social Security
okay
and that's basically his Social Security
income plus whatever other jobs that
either one of them can do given their
health situations and and then you say
that's how much money there is we need
to work out a plan where you guys can
live on that because we can't pay your
fifteen thousand dollars in medical
bills they're not going to get paid
right now and you can't pay them either
because you have to eat first that's a
rule and so if he has $3,000 a month
coming in and in Social Security and
they need $3,200 a month to exist that's
200 bucks I'm probably coming up with if
it delays something in your life yeah
I'm probably going to do that okay but
if it's if they need ten thousand to
exist and you're giving them two hundred
that's someone good money after bad you
have
really solve their problem so I want you
to get up under this and make sure that
what you're doing actually causes them
to be sustainable mathematically and
your husband is in this too and it
really he needs to lead the discussion
not you because you're gonna end up
being the evil greedy daughter-in-law if
you're not careful here okay you don't
want to be that one okay I mean that's
not you're gonna get posted in this and
so does your husband have any brothers
or sisters he does he has one younger
brother that is how old he's 17 he's
about to turn 18
good gracious so he's living with them
right and that's when their own come
will go down
cuz since he's on disability or sorry my
father-in-law's on disability they get a
check since they have a dependent but
once you think seeing that will go away
Wow okay so we're gonna lay out a game
plan that sustains them that may mean
moving it may mean doing a lot of
different things but 200 is not gonna
fix this situation nor is it going to
lay you but it's certainly ending
anything to do with you being a good
Christian you're just trying to be a
good person and help mom and dad it's
not a spiritual issue involved here and
I don't over spiritual eyes it